fired FBI director James Comey may have
been influenced during the Hillary
Clinton email investigation by a phony
Russian clue sources confirmed to CBS
News that a document obtained by the FBI
may have led Comey to criticize the
Democratic presidential candidates
handling of classified information while
she was Secretary of State that document
first reported by The Washington Post
was later addressed as bad intelligence
and maybe even a Russian made fake
Julianna Goldman is in Washington with
more on this story Julianna good morning
good morning Associates of Jim Comey say
he made the best decision he could with
the information he had but Clinton
campaign officials point to that July
press conference where he said she was
careless and handling classified
information as contributing to her loss
our judgment is that no reasonable
prosecutor would bring such a case when
former FBI director James Comey made the
unusual decision last July to announce
that Hillary Clinton would not face
charges sources say he held the press
conference himself in part because of
potentially game-changing intelligence
the FBI received in the spring of 2016
the documents cited a purported email
saying that then Attorney General
Loretta Lynch assured Clinton's campaign
that she wouldn't let the investigation
into her private email server get too
far that document was unreliable and
possibly a fake product of Russian
intelligence sources tell CBS News it
could have been part of the Kremlin's
plan to plant fake news into the
bloodstream of the election to discredit
Clinton but before it was discredited
the document reached the highest levels
of law enforcement call me believed that
if it got out it would discredit the
investigation they were extremely
careless Comey also decided not to
consult with Lynch or anyone at the
Department of Justice before his press
conference thank you very much shortly
after the FBI concluded the intelligence
was unreliable how and when did you
first learn of this document Republican
Senator Charles Grassley asked Comey
about the document earlier this month
did the FBI interview the person who
wrote the email if not why not
have to give you the same answer I can't
talk about that in an unclassified
setting that was commis last appearance
on the hill before he was fired charlie
Grassley and Senator Dianne Feinstein
wrote to Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosen Stein and acting FBI director
Andrew McCabe asking for a follow-up
briefing on questions Comey wasn't able
to answer they say they're still waiting
thanks Julianna